please welcome today's drew gooder joe
caramania
thank you
okay i hear you're known for being like
a donut connoisseur i can't even believe
this is in front of me right now
yeah i have a little bit of a reputation
i guess um i make comic books and
graphic novels for a living so i travel
to a lot of different comic conventions
across the country
and uh the joke is that i tell people to
bring me donuts or other sweet treats
and i'll pay them back in comics and
people do they they bring me donuts all
the time
and everywhere i travel i always
i seek out the local donut shop and i
sample it and test them out and
everything and i end up keeping in touch
with a lot of the shops on social media
and one of the shops is broad street
doco which is in oakhurst new jersey
they also have a sword freehold and they
actually gave me the opportunity to
create my own donut that i call the joe
nut the jonah that's so perfect
[Music]
how did you start matriculating and
associating donuts with like
philanthropy how did that happen
well pre-pandemic i used to raise money
for the ronald mcdonald house charities
um at different comic conventions and i
would put a little change box in front
of me at the meet and greet table and
people come by and drop in like five
dollars ten dollars and i would give
them signed comics in return but
unfortunately because of the pandemic a
lot of live events
kind of went away for a while and krispy
kreme announced their promotion that
they would give away one free glazed
donut every day if you show your
vaccination that's right we did a story
about that on the news yeah right and i
take a walk every morning as part of my
just daily routine
so there's a store that happens to be a
mile away from my house so i turned that
into my daily walk and started going
every day and i would post pictures of
me with my free donut on social media
and put a little silly caption or
something and try to encourage people to
get vaccinated
and people seem to enjoy it
and i decided that i would
do something and kind of tie in my love
for the ronald mcdonald house charities
and i decided to give one dollar for
every free donut i got like the money
i'm saving on donuts i'll donate to the
ronald mcdonald house in winston-salem
north carolina and this is personal for
you the ronald mcdonald house will you
tell us why sure
when my oldest daughter julia was born
she had some life-threatening
complications and she had to be
transported to another hospital a
children's hospital and that's pretty
much where
my wife and i lived for the first month
of her life
but i remember feeling very lucky
actually because my wife and i actually
lived somewhat close to the hospital so
we were able to go back and forth to
home and we saw some families there that
didn't have that situation and they had
to sleep in waiting rooms and pushing
like two chairs together to make a bed
and years later i found out what it is
that the ronald mcdonald house actually
does and that's provide a home away from
home for families with seriously ill
children that have to travel a long
distance to go to the hospital
and as soon as i found that out i knew
that that's a mission that i wanted to
be a part of because i actually saw the
the need for it oh
you're so i love this so much you're
such a good person thank you so glad
that you're doing this thank you
that you had to go through that i'm so
grateful that you were able to turn your
pain and fear into this awareness and
take care of others
our friends at the make sense foundation
founded by senegence a female-owned
cosmetic brand heard what you are doing
and they wanted to help so they are
donating ten
thousand dollars to the ronald mcdonald
house of the piedmont triad in your
honor joe oh thank you so much that's
amazing thank you um there's also um we
know that you've walked over 400 miles
for a good cause and we wanted to give
you something to keep you on your feet
so you could keep doing all the good
things you're doing and dramatic is
going to give you a massage chair
believe me
we have one upstairs and the entire crew
uses it we all take turns oh wow
so
maybe you can kick back eat a donut and
realize that there are thousands and
thousands and thousands of dollars going
to ronald mcdonald houses thank you so
much that's very kind i'm gonna have to
fight my kids for use of that massage
chair
you if you saw us here we're all
fighting each other for it it works like
a charm um joe thank you for doing what
you're doing and bringing awareness um
to the ronald mcdonald house really and
truly thank you so much for giving me
the opportunity to talk about it because
the first time i ever heard about the
ronald mcdonald house was on a radio
show so i know how this can lead to like
good things just putting it out there
for people to see let's hope that it
does let's try if you go to the
drewberrymoreshow.com you learn all
about how to donate to the ronald
mcdonald house and support them thank
you joe
[Music]